as Democrats consider withholding the
materials the Senate would need for an
impeachment trial Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell is accusing House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi of being quote too
afraid to present the case the standoff
means the entire impeachment process is
in uncharted territory Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill Nancy why the holdup
while Speaker Pelosi says that she wants
to know more Anthony about what this
Senate trial is going to look like
before she sends the charges to the
Senate but leader McConnell after
meeting with his Democratic counterpart
Chuck Schumer said that the two sides
are at an impasse I'm not sure what
leverage there is in refraining from
sending us something we do not want
leader McConnell called the Democrats
case for impeachment week after speaker
Pelosi suggested she might wait to send
the articles of impeachment to the
Senate will see whether House Democrats
ever want to work up the courage to
actually take their accusation to trial
frankly I don't care like every public
se Pelosi was just as scathing about
McConnell who has vowed to work in
lockstep with the White House on this
trial our founders and when they wrote
the Constitution they suspected that
there could be a rogue president I don't
think they suspected that we could have
a rogue president and a rogue leader in
the Senate at the same time she has the
backing of House Democrats who are
looking for ways to pressure the Senate
into calling key witnesses like acting
White House chief of staff Mick Mulvaney
and former national security adviser
John Bolton Sherman do you run the risk
of
like you're playing games with
impeachment if you do not intervene not
playing games of impeachment this is the
third time in our history you wouldn't
have done it if you weren't deadly
serious Senate Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer had his first meeting with
McConnell about the trial yesterday I
told Leader McConnell that we would not
support any trial without witnesses and
documents South Carolina Senator Lindsey
Graham called the democratic strategy
constitutional extortion I just left
President Trump he's mad as hell that
they would do this to him and now deny
him his day in court
think of all of these ultimatums as the
opening salvos in a negotiation over how
long this trial is going to be and how
comprehensive it is going to be and it's
important Gail because this trial will
determine whether President Trump stays
in office all right Nancy it continues
in marital counseling they told me
ultimatums never work so we'll see what
happens
you